كانت هناك مشكلة أكبر
طرأت على بريانا وهي أنك تعلم أننا
نفكر في تصاريح استخدام الطوارئ هذه
عادةً لأن شخصًا ما في
المستشفى مريض جدًا ،
فقد حاولنا تجربة شيء ما لإنجاح العمل
، لا يوجد بديل آخر ،
هل يمكنك حقًا قول الشيء نفسه  حول
لقاح ، أعني أنك تعرف أن
ما يمكننا فعله هو ارتداء الأقنعة
والمسافة الجسدية التي رأيناها
في بلدان أخرى حول العالم
والتي ستكون بديلاً مقبولاً ،
لذلك سألته
بالنظر إلى سبب الاندفاع حول
هذا ما قاله
لماذا تتعجل ، لماذا لا تنتظر ، تأكد
حتى لبضعة أشهر من عدم وجود
آثار جانبية أخرى غير عادية
من وجهة نظر السلامة ،
ونشجع الناس فقط
على إخفاء الأشياء والمسافة التي لا
نراها في هذا البلد لا
تزال حقيقة الحياة هنا
وفي كل مكان  وإلا في البلدان
التي لديها
مستويات مختلفة من الانتقال والسيطرة ،
إذا كنا غير قادرين على السيطرة على هذا
الوباء ،
فلن أقبل أبدًا
تقديم لقاح مثل
كل
شخص آخر أتفاعل معه ،
يجب أن أقول
إن لقاحًا غير آمن يتم
تقديمه ،
لذا أود أن أقلب
السؤال بصراحة في الاتجاه المعاكس وأقول
ما هو السبب
الأخلاقي لحجب اللقاح الذي يمكنني القيام به
تطورت بشكل أسرع
من التطور بشكل أسرع